can you imagine a Democrat being
targeted uh like that by a candidate for
attorney general because that's what's
happening with brag that's what's
happening with Leticia James that's
what's happening with Fanny Willis uh
does that sound like Equal justice Blind
Justice in America I don't think so and
some Democrats apparently have law
enforcement helping them cover up their
crimes let me give you a prime example
we just learned the wife of New Jersey
senator recently indicted Bob Menendez
says reportedly killed The Pedestrian
with her car back in 2018 now the
Senator's wife was cleared pretty
quickly of any wrongdoing by the police
and allowed to leave the scene according
to the New York Times she was not tested
for any drugs or alcohol the incident
was never reported publicly until now
how convenient uh and by the way she
allegedly later got a replacement car
the Mercedes convertible listed in the
indictment uh it's nice to have good
friends kilos of gold tons of everybody
has 500 Grand of cash living on a
senator salary right laying around their
house in their pockets stuffed down
their sheets whatever anyway here with
reaction to all of it Fox News
contributor Jonathan Turley Jonathan
welcome
back
Professor if I'm wrong I guess I would
fail in your class but why do I believe
that we shouldn't have people in that
are running for positions like da like
Brad in New York or Leticia James AG or
Fanny Willis down in Georgia that are
campaigning to go after one person by
name one family by name one organization
by name uh that seems to me that they're
going in with the predetermined agenda
uh and making that a campaign promise
and in those positions they have an
awful lot of power don't
they they do and when James was running
for office I wrote that I thought there
were serious ethical problems uh with a
prosecutor uh really trying to secure
office on the pledge to nail one person
this is a trophy pledge that I'm going
to bag Donald Trump and not mentioning
what he might be charged with I'm just
going to charge him with something and
that should be an embarrassment to the
entire New York Bar I think that brag
should be an embarrassment his case uh
is in my view just ridiculous it it
barely holds together but this is part
of this recreational use of the laws to
pursue unpopular persons now I'm not
saying that there's not going to be any
Merit to the question about these
filings for banks and and Loans but the
question is is this selective in in
isolating the Trump business because I
wrote earlier that James has expressed
very little interest in Liberal
organizations that have been accused of
similar conduct she's gone against she's
gone after the NRA she's gone after
Trump uh she has really developed the
signature that she will use all of the
levers of her office to go against
political opponents yeah let me let me
ask you this question so we're watching
the case down in maralago at issue and
this case that actually taking place in
New York about the Trump organization
they want to take they want to put all
Trump properties in re receivership so
they'd have no control take $250 million
prevent them from ever doing business in
New York for at least 5 years not that
they'd ever want to um and what's really
amazing to me is that issue is the idea
that Donald Trump somehow on his
financial applications for loans and
insurance policies inflated the cost and
the estimates of of their value now
there is a disclaimer I read it on the
air last night in every contract where
it says do not take our our evaluations
to heart that basically these financial
institutions have their own fiduciary
responsibility to come up with their own
figures on that and by the way I don't
know a single lender in the world that
would say oh you think your home is
worth a billion dollars no problem and
and here's and here's the irony of this
then the judge uses a tax assessment
even though the town of Palm Beach told
him not to do so he literally said maral
Lago worth what any where between $8 and
$26 million well if you get a one and a
half if you get a 2 acre plot of land
there's one for sale just dirt and
there's 20 acres of maral Lago that's
$200 million right now an acre that's
a175 million you can go check it out on
uh trulia.com or one of those websites
so how does this judge do exactly what
they're accusing Donald Trump of and not
give a proper assessment how does that
play out in this case cuz to me that's
pretty
despicable well this is going to have to
play out because it has to be with to
withstand a pellet review the difficulty
for the Trump team is that the New York
law is almost unique it doesn't require
uh an intent to defraud and it doesn't
require that anyone lost money in fact
the Trump team is is arguing that these
Banks made a lot of money nobody lost a
cent so there's no classic victim in the
sense but under the New York law you
don't have to cost anyone a dime for
James to demand what's called
discouragement of profits and that's
what she's arguing for here but she's
using a nuclear option here uh which I
can't understand and demanding all of
this relief yeah uh uh Professor always
great to have you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get get it anywhere
else